[Music]
all right can you uh you say your
full-name sir tell them I like my full
name I mean your name there be a
government name just be your name like
the name that I want to say yeah I'm Rob
Hayes Rob hates their being on the show
man thanks for having me though no
problem man um let's get into it you one
2051 to go than 15 let's go fast in in
the Scopus you made it I won the whole
year but I was so on the skull face well
I got asked from a family perspective I
know you've had jokes about you bombing
a friend your dad and not being thrilled
in you quoted your sister saying you
didn't try to make me cry in the
introduction is that she's let's talk
about those bombs all right no it's
about I'm just saying you won the skull
fest yeah yeah which is not that great
is more about your dad saying you bomb
and him not being thrilled about you
being Union you didn't come to scoff as
that one and then but you're also your
sister said you know that being comedian
is like the worst job you could have so
has their you know who have you been
talking to huh huh
I was recently intervention researchers
let me give me the quit absolute
opposite I'm on the fence right now Joe
okay this is this okay
this is public knowledge no you are
coming at me right now yeah well the
whole point of this was to ask since you
won the skull fest as if their point of
view has changed
yeah I don't think I don't think that I
vomit in front of my dad was more of an
effect on me I think than an effect on
him like those just wore me psyching
myself out and when my sister said that
that's when I this one we were in high
school like I was I was
young we vote for you like and I think
her opinion has changed I feel like she
probably doesn't even feel feel that way
anymore especially after like you know
more knowledge of stand up you know you
what do you what do you know about
standing up right near that edge you
know you know what you saw The Fresh
Prince that was people making fun of
people so that's why she said that was a
weird job because she said that it's the
worst job because you her opinion of the
of it at the time was people getting
paid thousands of dollars to make people
feel horrible
Oh in front of people you know so it's
seen a different light now yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it they're supportive oh
yeah yeah they're fully supportive well
that's what's up how was it that's case
your family life is good it's yeah it's
good it's good
how about your life after the skull fest
what is change and you know just sex
drugs rock and roll
it's crazy out here man you know I mean
what these people would do for somebody
no no it's the same it's the same hasn't
changed too much I mean I don't know
I've kind of already had the moments
where people kind of switched up so now
it's just like it's like just putting
the battery in in that switch up again
you know like like it I guess
I've already had kind of kind of some
stuff happen where people like Oh Rob's
here oh yeah we gotta be nice to Rob cuz
he like I don't know what they think I'm
gonna do I don't know if they think I
was just like I don't know become Tyler
Perry and open a studio in East Atlanta
so I don't know what they think is gonna
happen but yeah but that I felt like I'm
beyond the switch-up I don't think I
don't think if you could switch up
anymore well you're certainly someone
who as a compliment
alright you're you're funny and you're
able to navigate the network side of the
industry you know some people though be
some people can navigate but then when
they get on stage
they're not funny yeah so what do you
think what is kind of your strategy
maybe or what have you done that you
think other people don't when it comes
to the networking aspect of stand-up
comedy my focus is not on network my
focus is just on the stage just trying
to be you know the best performer I can
beat and then I mean most of the
opportunities I've gotten have come from
just doing good work and then the right
the right people seeing me I mean every
now and then I'll make a decision and
I'll be like I don't know like we have
to choose between shows and stuff and I
try to like for the longest who's just
like what's the longest set it wasn't
about the money the distance it was like
who's gonna give me the most time okay
you got 20 minutes over here and in the
back of the shed four versus five
minutes in this club I'm gonna go to the
[ __ ] and do 20 just because I want to
know what 20 feels like you know so it
just depends
and then like later for that man I went
to the club but like initially I went to
the [ __ ] so you're right started from
the shed now we're here and now we're
here yeah but it has the skull fest
gotten you more work as far as longer
shows in clubs and environments like
that oh it's coming it's coming it's
coming this definitely longer work that
comes from that and the expectation is
like alright this guy you know if he's
if he's got you know you do five minutes
then you do seven minutes and you're
eight minutes since all of like you know
against other people doing their best
stuff you know the assumption is this
guy has the time he's you know
headlining and so when I when I do those
gigs it's like I'm ready to prove it in
like yeah I got it I can do it you know
and I don't know doing the longer set is
it's all about like pacing it's all
about like figuring out with the
audience like like being able to control
them the entire Brian
you know mm-hmm so that about control I
know you just recently headlined the
Improv mm-hmm and you're doing it again
in May yeah oh yeah may 28th May 20th
come out it's gonna be crazy last time
was crazy
this is muck that was like the most fun
I've ever had at The Improv and that
made me realize like when they say just
go and then you just go as long as you
want it's like ooh I can go in there
like some cool places like some places I
haven't been since and some places that
I don't know where we go you know that's
that's cool and fun and stuff you found
some moments to build on that headlining
sense yeah yeah of course of course some
moments to build on some moments that I
can never have happen again you know
some stuff where people like I didn't
know that you know I didn't know I don't
know how many tickets I'm selling with
this like like we just talked about me
bombing and I'm doing stuff yeah yeah
don't you know don't don't base your
opinion on what you just heard all right
patient opinion on what we were talking
about we're talking about how I'm funny
I'm gonna make you laugh right now what
we're talking about how I can make you
laugh it's a nice aside from well Paige
you doing more headlining gigs now do
you think you have enough experience as
a feature that you're ready to headline
I don't think that makes sense I think I
got good at five minutes by doing five
minutes I got good at 20 minutes by
doing 20 minutes the only way I'm gonna
be good at out at an hour is by
continuing to do an hour so I'm still
like very young in like that our side of
things but it's that's my focus right
now so you you've been headlining some
clubs but also a bit also some colleges
as well yeah so what how do you compare
and contrast those two processes
different audience expectations you know
like a club pretty much 21 and up
college be 18 to 21 year old so and
mainly 18 and
you know so you got people who don't
have the same experiences they don't get
the same references they're more
sensitive at a college but then also the
college that lets you like sometimes
I'll let you play more sometimes you
know you can like get give the thing
going and write it out you know as long
as it goes and in the club you know
there's this any expectations you got
comedy fans there you got people there
who kind of used to a certain thing so
you got to kind of give them that or if
you if you depart from that then you
know you got to be ready for them to
kind of not be ready for that a little
bit you know
do you prefer one over the other right
now I prefer people who want to see and
comedy show like if I do a school and
it's a bunch of people that they'd like
like oh man well we don't give you out
hot wings but before that we got a
comedian and that's not as fun as during
the school where everybody's like oh man
I never seen a comedian before man I'm
so excited you know you're here you know
you're here now this town like no one
ever comes here you came here you know
like like that's always great or you
know doing a club full of people who are
like and we want to see comedy or we
want to see you or I saw a picture of
you and I was like man this guy's gonna
be funny you know embrace is going on
place and they're like oh man we thought
it was so-and-so tonight now they're not
easier tomorrow but you know right so
this guy yeah we got this guy so is this
I just I just like audiences that are
like receptive I even I don't even have
to come to see me but I just gotta come
to see County and then I can I can work
from there you talk about a lot of
colleges being like oh there's comedy
I've never seen comedy but then they're
sensitive yeah they're sensitive because
they know they don't know that that
certain lines are gonna be crossed by
either either that expectation is the
she's just gonna go on stage would be
the worst person ever or their
expectation is that like I don't know I
don't know what they expect where they
expected you know you're gonna get
everyone to laugh and not push any
buttons like that I guess they want
Fozzie Bear to come onstage or something
you know waka waka waka right you know
he'd kill yo fozzy you said college
brave man I'll set out the Fozzie Bear
yeah I follow him on Instagram I'm
trying to open for Fozzie Bear but it's
hard cuz you know he's gonna be one too
open for you man you sure I hope so man
you know there's a lot of good most be
expensive though because you gotta bring
heavy I bring his his handler you know I
mean I'm ringing the dude who puts a
hand you know I want to put his personal
business out there but you know he's got
some dudes with some hands but we're not
gonna talk about insurance liability as
well clearly I mean you've been rubbing
elbows with people like Fozzie Bear yeah
yeah yeah positive is crazy
how's that affected you on the business
side as far as representation where is
your status on that do people talk about
that on podcast do they talk about who's
represented them yeah Oh like names no
just in the south I represent a little
bit a little bit over Orlando yeah what
are you getting this from yeah talking
about who have you been talking to me
how do you know about Orlando
this is Google this is on Google yeah
if people don't know Rob Hays was voted
and creative loafing is one of the top
artists to watch in the city and in that
artist people two eyes like you people
in general watching right yeah watch me
so yeah and that was just mentioned in
that article in your childhood it was
you starting in Atlanta went to Orlando
and then came back yeah we moved to
Orlando when I was 1 and then from 1 to
7
we lived on land
then we moved back here to Atlanta when
I was like seven yes so during the OJ
trial we moved back and I don't know if
those years are crucial or not I feel
like they they do affect the way I speak
I feel like I don't I don't have an
Atlanta accent because I learned how to
talk in Florida but at the same time I
don't know if they affect like like I
don't feel like I always feel connected
to Atlanta but I don't I don't know when
I think about those days I don't think
about Orlando I think about like Saved
by the Bell
do you remember Orlando I just remember
what I was watching on TV
I remember like The Simpsons and Martin
and lemon-coloured and stuff I don't
remember like a little bit we played
Street I can you know went outside and
stuff it was never never cold
you know who's short see you around and
stuff like that but I don't know the
early years you know earlier yeah that's
where the seed was sown yes on Orlando
make you the man you are today yeah
that's where I first got introduced of
Fozzie Bear was when I was in Orlando
yeah a good time well we're grateful you
came back to Atlanta because now you are
making waves in this city and we don't
even have bodies of water it's amazing
how I'm doing that and sound waves radio
waves waves from the audience when I'm
walking through the crowd after the
stage day and what sets with that's what
I do now I do my closer mm-hmm stage
dive yeah and then they they carry me to
like the back of the club and I take
pictures with people that's why they
call you the haze inator this one they
copy the hesitating because I'll be back
they book me again did you stage-dive
when you open for Chappelle oh no no no
no they told me hey we we know about
your closing that's like a year
you can't jump off the stage I was like
alright so what was that experience like
oh man it was it was crazy it was fun
right it was great tonight guy I got to
see him perform for free like that was
like the the best part was like getting
a see Chappelle like like seven times
man for free that's the same yeah like
we were at like I was head like like six
months before that I paid like $70 and
went to see him as did I and I was I was
happy about that and I was happy that he
was back I was just happy that I got the
chance to like see him and like like not
only did I get to open form but I get to
like open for him again then I get to
open for him again and he sees my set
mm-hmm
you know and he's like telling me like
oh man that jokes plenty of olivine I'm
like you're you like yeah you know it's
like man like forget getting though
though like I think Chappelle show is
one of those things that like got
everybody's wheels turning event like
stand up and just comedy period and it's
just it was so funny and everything in
hit on was everything I cared about at
the time you know and what did you learn
from seeing him seven times so much I
mean there was so much that didn't he
was he's so comfortable on stage you
know like I mean you'd have a foot on a
speaker I'd be scared I'm gonna kick it
over something like like someone is
jokes you just lay down on the stage and
just be like like like in this body
language it's like guys listen to me
you know and then also dealing with like
people love them so much that they want
to like yell out stuff you know they
wanna like they like we can't hold it in
they got he's got catchphrases on
catchphrases and they
let him know what catchphrase affected
them and and him being able to handle
that and and taking like a like like a
theater it's like two thousand people
but the vibe is not like you're in a
room with two thousand people even to
the point where he's like I got some
cigarettes and like somebody like we
could throw some cigarettes like
somebody with a arm has cigarettes like
and then he's like the only person who
can smoke in the building and he's just
smoking and it feels like he's just
smoking and talking so you know amazed
what did he have for you I mean as far
as you said he liked that one joke were
you guys able to interact with each
other was the approachable I was able to
talk to him a little bit um I mean I
wasn't I wasn't on the bus with him but
I was able to talk to him a little bit
and yeah there were there was a moment
he told me like one of my jokes was
plenty and stuff and that made me feel
like the world like I'll never stop
doing the gas up company it's only this
joke was funny I'm gonna be doing it so
like 15 years I would just keep changing
the date on it it's just like you know
what the other day like what do you mean
ya don't relate no the other day on my
iPhone 3 that's gotta stop it allowed my
razor right and get a blackberry message
from my homeboys know what I something
to cross off the bucket list for sure
yeah yeah that wasn't even on my bucket
list
I even think of that as a possibility if
you was like write down your goals I
wouldn't write that down cuz I'm like
this it's not going to happen okay I'm
just gonna just gonna do that I'm also
gonna be on the cast of The Fresh Prince
to season 7 they're gonna bring you back
you know saying like like okay and I'm
gonna ride rainbows it just didn't seem
like it was a real thing you know
well what goals have you written down I
wrote down a bunch of goals in 2011 and
then my bookbag guy
stolen and they stole like all my
notebooks and everything and then a lot
of those girls I like accomplished like
those my in my five-year plan I've
already accomplished a lot of this stuff
in less than five years so I realized it
like I don't dream big enough to write
down goals like I need to just like I
don't know I guess something wasn't
realistic
you know about like how things were
going in the rate of things and
everything so I don't know I mean you're
clearly I mean one of the hottest acts
around right now and you're based in
Atlanta I mean where does where do you
see the trajectory going I know a lot of
people from the city have moved to LA or
New York are you like a homebody you
want to watch this scene keep
progressing I'm trying to move to
Cleveland
LeBron moved there you know Iman
Shumpert JR Smith and I mean you know
Kevin Hart he did seriously funny there
mm-hmm and if I'm gonna take funny
seriously I need to go to Cleveland so I
think I'm gonna take my talents to
Cleveland that is a wise choice yeah
yeah our house was a good good state you
know they just want a national
championship football so I mean if you
want watch sports I mean that's why all
the athletes are so I get them to
co-sign me you know like LeBron James
has got he's got a show you know he's
always on ESPN so all I need to do is
you know write for his press conferences
and stuff and then sooner or later you
gonna see me so Cleveland before I've
been I've been before yeah yeah in
Emily's no I didn't do comedy there I
just I just went to a family reunion but
yeah you have fun performed in New York
though right yeah I've formed in New
York I've performed in New York City it
was great every time I go up there I
love it I just did a school in Oneonta
New York upstate New Year it was
negative 11 degrees as a coldest my body
has ever been not equipped for the
negatives by everybody else was just
like cool duh it was like they were used
to like your being that cold meanwhile
like I'm up there freaking out like I'm
pumping gas and I sound like I'm having
sex well I don't know why I was making
the girl noises but it was too cold I
saw a horse with a coat oh that's too
cold did it affect your performance at
all um yeah I feel like I talked about
the weather for like 30 minutes do I
have this show it is cold outside you
know like the snow is like powdery you
can't even throw it it's like all right
yeah we know that like move on you know
something else
let's go like yeah they were a little
sensitive that material I don't know I
think they were like man if you'll stop
reminding us how cold it is right also
up there we went to this restaurant and
it was it was a yellow diner it was
something it was a cold had the
restaurant and it was old yeah coal and
like the way the students came up
there's I hey you want to go to this
restaurant we take all the comedian's
there start by a cold and it's like what
like what you say like you know coke
they do the rest and we're like what
they're like but the food is good so
then we get there the food was good
below and the bathroom was like
scriptures like carved into the story
and stuff and like all the people look
like they were the same like either they
were in a family but they didn't look
like I couldn't put a finger on what
race they were like they were like some
new kind of hybrid some kind of hybrid
yeah something something's going on
they're like I don't know I never seen
people that look like that before and it
was all made of wood they look like
something out of
like a like a Jim Henson production life
is very Jim Henson evite Wow yeah so you
prefer the Hotlanta to up in New York
I prefer Hatton in a lot of places I
don't but I don't know any black
anyplace else really I mean I lived in
Athens for a couple of years better than
that I've only lived really in that land
do you think you can get what you want
out of your comedy career in Atlanta
yeah I feel like I could I feel like me
wanting to move be me wanting to just
venture out and experience other things
in my life you know I think I don't
think Ellen has a limit as far as comedy
as much as personally you know my
experiences is in this in this place
that's a very polar you know it's only
black and white and there's so much
other world out there there's so many
other different types of people out
there and I kind of want to experience
that maybe you know you have a strategy
to get into that mood you in the process
right don't have a strategy I don't have
this time I've been wrestling with this
is my lack of strategy very very Busch
like with my the way I've been going
about things well you're good at getting
political now guys hard hidden issues
that's right 2004 are you gonna vote for
my money's on John Kerry what do you
think I'm voting don't look watch him
throw a baseball I'm just gonna say I'm
I'm voting for a Sanjaya Sanjaya on fire
he's gonna wait two years till Sanjaya
kids on American Idol and then I was
that was that a 806 that was oh eight
maybe I don't know
Sanjaya those are good old days well I
like I like your optimism with the city
of Atlanta and you feel like there's a
lot going on but mm-hmm
as far as the timeline of your career
yeah where does it stand you content or
your hunger you've been building
momentum hungry
you know I need like either get in the
accident get shot or something psycho
really like build the ultimate momentum
and uh you know like did he think I shot
nine times that worked out for him
pretty well
and then kind of got in the accident so
I need some I guess I can't do what they
did to really make it but think what if
a comment got shot nine times and then
did a special about it like that would
be pretty insane right
I like of a comment got a car I guess
y'all watch the special with his jaw
wired up set and the specialist called
through the wire like that I ain't
pretty
I'd be pretty crazy everybody cries I
need to get struck by lightning so I for
ya yeah I know beyond comedy acting is
another Avenue you want to get into yep
yep yeah so where are you as far as
getting into that world I've been
writing my own stuff and trying to like
put stuff together cuz I'm I realized
like Kastner people don't they don't see
the vision I guess they don't like when
they see me they'll know what to do with
me like it sometimes I have to read for
stuff and I'll be like there's no way
I'm getting this this got this character
name is guy with dreads like just like
act a certain way to be guy with dreads
like they want guy with dreads to to act
a certain way I guess and I guess I
could act like that but if they really
want to go address there's somebody out
there with address there's plenty of
people out there with dreads
maybe you should just go to different
castings at least I'm here to read for a
guy with dreads I have to try it's in my
pocket you guys do CGI right
that's good you're doing auditions
though are these more things you found
on your own or just the representation
just people like find out about me and
then they send me stuff and then I go do
it and then I never hear from them again
so I don't know definitely want to cross
over into acting you thinking I want to
cross over into acting I mean I I'm a
real big fan of Louis CK's show I'm a
real big fan of Woody Allen
I think Woody Allen's movie is a genius
and I've been watching his step since I
was in high school so I just if I if I
got an acting it would it would have to
be like that would have to be me just
creating my own thing and then and then
putting myself in it you know yeah all
you yeah like Spike Lee's in a bunch of
Spike Lee movies like that I would have
to it would have to be like that
like I don't I don't see anything coming
and somebody's been like I got this part
and it's for you I even if they do that
I probably still mess it up well why
don't you think there's been more of
Woody Allen's in Louis CK's with that
kind of autonomy on their art um Louise
deal is crazy no one like like most
people are not trying with people in
their ear not trying to do something
like that like he's like he goes to FX
ins like what's the most money you'll
give me to not see what I do before I
send it in and they're like this amount
and he's like alright well give me that
amount and you'll get ten episodes
there's no where no one does no one
should do business like that if Louie
wasn't a genius whoever signed off that
money would have to be in a meeting
they're like well like I know this
amount is pretty low for ten episodes
but still we don't have the type of
money for you to just give to people
blindly and then just get like like
luckily Louie's like making the best
show on television but and he's earnest
yeah but like you give ten comics that
amount of money and be like yo dude ten
episode
and they'll just gonna be like no I need
more money there's something you know
you say having that freedom is your goal
but now you're saying that it's almost
impossible nobody should take that kind
of deal no the deal the deal is crazy
but what Louis doing is not crazy like
what Louis doing is is cool and and you
don't need the deep like that type of
like Louie's getting paid to do it
but if fluid made that show for the
internet somebody would pick it up like
Louis just like knows he knows what he's
doing so he can gamble like that because
he knows what he's doing and so for me
in order I got to first figure out what
I'm doing but then after I know what I'm
doing there'll be no stopping me I mean
there's money a big motivator in your
career you just more of the expression
type and you just get money that'll help
you survive I just wanna like in
anything I do I just wanted to be good I
just wanna be Wanna be funny in it you
know right now I just so I'm not I'm not
a I'm not not motivated by money because
I've made I don't have anything so you
know it's not like I'm in a place right
now I don't think I could turn down
anything like I'll I'll do anything like
if I'm available I'll do it like you
like I don't do when I turned down
something's because I got something else
like and I can't do both mm-hmm
so I said that but at the same time I'm
I don't know I I don't like it like I
think I would rather just do great stuff
than try to like the highest grossing
kimete you know they don't wanna be that
guy I want to be like hey Rob did good
work well there's certain you on your
way Rob days you know thank you I
appreciate you coming on the show
is that it this is the end of the show
yeah you just end it like that yeah did
you need anything else
yeah everything there's some family
Orlando bombing highs and lows what do
you want the people to know I want the
people is no more aware all right you
know I got this like rash on the back of
my neck I don't know like I scratch it
and it gets worse
it's just wondering what I should do
about that I would say in my
professional opinion yeah - we're not
scratch it that's good yeah yeah okay
you can take a look at it all right
thank you that's that's my baby that's
what you want to be married guys nothing
coming comedian on his way to the top I
have a rash that's was my artistic
choice I really don't have a rash ladies
you feel the back of my neck if you want
it's on the neck it's not contagious on
the neck it's not contagious on the neck
well I mean where you are right now in
your career just in the few years have
been doing stand-up did you even see
yourself as making these many gains this
early I thought my neck would be in way
better shape no I did not but I did like
I you know I'm not arrogant at the same
time I always somewhat like I always I
think in everyone's head is the
narrative of like you know a star is
born and then you know you know like the
first time you walk in the comedy club
you look at all the pictures like one
day my pitch is gonna be up in it you
know I feel like that's and everybody
said but at the same time that doesn't
mean because it's in your head it has to
happen so sometimes it's like bugged out
sometimes it's like really tripped out
to think like man like I remember when I
knew nothing but I thought oh I'm gonna
be up there
doing good and then like I was up there
and eventually I knew what it felt like
to be up there doing good and then it's
like oh you see somebody close out of
open mic oh my god I just want to close
that open mic and then close that home I
feel like that was nothing you know
still bugged out you know do you worry
about getting too much too soon
no you don't feel like there's any
hesitation as far as maybe not being
prepared for a next level
no no cuz that's part of it part of it
is getting too much too soon the first
time you work on a weekend it's too much
too soon if the first time that you
feature is too much too soon the first
time you can close that out of my first
time and close out of coffee shop you
know so you just you just keep going all
I can do is just just try to do
something every day try to do something
every night try to just keep at it as
much as I can and just be the best Rob
that I can be at that time so I don't
know and ain't comedy is one of those
things were like it all evens out like
if you think like oh I'm gonna like put
the cheat codes in and skip this level
no not in comedy you said I make people
laugh if they come to me tomorrow like
Robert you got a host the Oscars some
like like this year then it would be
like what they don't be like would this
good know who is crazy who do I hire
what
you know but that's not gonna happen but
at the same time if I'm playing their
position I'm not gonna be like well I
can't do that I'm not gonna do that I
know my watch the movies in China you
know try to be like will get unknowns
every that's a crazy scenario but if the
Academy's listening how let your boy man
y'all know where to find me
not in Orlando anymore anymore yeah
welcome to you yeah
2026 seniors I look out they haven't
picked out yet so you know I'm not gonna
rule that out I'm on Twitter at Robert
is the man on Twitter I'll spell
correctly you can find me on Instagram
Rob Hayes our OB h AZ e that's also I
have a Facebook page and a Facebook fan
page I'm at under 5,000 friends on
Facebook so if you want to be on my
facebook friend I add everybody now it's
like there's no there's no number
crunching anymore it's just trying to
get the 5,000 so that when people add me
they'd be like well he must be legit
he's he's over the living witness of my
own I'm on snapchat Hayes Rob I don't
know what I'm doing on there and I'm
scared that he use it when I'm not in
Wi-Fi so it's mainly stuff from my house
but have you found social media to help
your career it doesn't hurt it like I
remember seeing tourgasm that show with
Dane Cook and he said like you got to
get on stuff when they first start like
he he blew up off MySpace right but like
before myspace was hitting everybody up
on AIM he was on AOL real heavy and he
got those people who got on myspace like
Lil Duval got on myspace people who go
to Twitter you know Kevin Hart got his
Twitter people to go there you know Jeff
Dunham guys to email people to go to
YouTube
so whatever the people blow up on
they get their following from a
different platform so whenever I see
something I get on it because if I blow
up on something like that it doesn't
have to go away like like yeah it goes
away from the people for that that's all
they have but if if you have a legit
stand-up show and you blow up on social
media there's no stopping you so it's
important but I haven't figured out my
lane in that yet but I'm still learning
it's a necessary Avenue it's a necessary
Avenue yeah because there are cats like
DC young fly over two million followers
yeah doesn't stand up a couple times but
can get booked you did read the last
night you open for my kelp sit Phillips
Arena and last night yeah Wow is that
cool with you yeah yeah they did compel
whether he's on the show bunk like it
wasn't like I was about to go up and
they were like hey I'm sorry I know
stage that was gonna be crazy but yeah
that's a night buddy like know so yeah
there's that's great you know is getting
room
you've bestowed a lot of wisdom I hope
everyone becomes wiser by listening to
me
anything else you in the to hear rob
Hayes Oh
[Music]
lalalalala
yeah that's it that's what I've needed
them in here cut that's what's up
nice job oh thank and you're staying in
Atlanta I'm everywhere
I'm everywhere you're not gonna move I'm
going to Tatooine Tatooine yeah are you
gonna leave us I'm gonna go to New York
or LA be a podracer you leaving us
you're gonna be a podracer mm-hmm so
you're staying here I'm going to the
mother ship well don't leave us remember
where you came from no no no don't probe
me I'm gonna come back and tell you yeah
already
all right Robbie's didn't get a straight
answer on that one but that's alright
what do you mean straight to the moon
straight answer right there you go
straight up I've seen Apollo 13 they did
it wrong you gotta make sure you don't
have any problems and then you you go
straight up all right good job I think
we learned a lot about Rob Hayes yep and
we look forward to seeing the trajectory
of this shooting star thank you so much
Joe thank you rob
I breath